certaines de ces questions seront
également abordées à kiev par catherine
colonna la nouvelle chef de la
diplomatie française qui effectue ce
matin son premier déplacement en ukraine
où elle va s'entretenir avec volodymyr
zelensky elle évolue en ce moment même
avec son homologue et demi trop cool et
bat baptiste falgos bonjour vous avez
des nouvelles du terrain un premier
déplacement donc pour la chef de la
diplomatie française en terre
ukrainienne est d'ailleurs la plus haute
représentante française à se rendre sur
place oui elle se rend sur place et
finalement elle commence par ce qui est
presque un passage obligé pour les
dignitaires étrangers aujourd'hui en
ukraine la ville de boudhha cette ville
symbole du martyr des populations
civiles face aux exactions attribuées à
l'armée russe elle s'y rend comme s'y
sont rendus de nombreux prédécesseurs et
elle va ensuite vous l'avez dit
rencontrer son homologue ukrainien donc
du ministère des affaires étrangères mis
trop coulé bas puis le président
volodymyr zelensky l'objectif majeur en
plus bien sûr d'apporter un soutien
symbolique fort à l'ukraine c'est
surtout d'évoquer en croire le
communiqué de la diplomatie française
c'est millions de tonnes de céréales qui
sont bloqués dans les ports de la mer
noire au par deux ne serait-ce que vous
parlez du blé tout à leur blé plus maïs
on a plus de 20 millions de tonnes de
céréales qui sont bloqués soit dans les
silos des ports de la mer noire qui sont
sous blocus russe soit dans les
entrepôts des fermes ukrainienne est
aujourd'hui les risques d'une crise
alimentaire mondiale son prix de plus en
plus au sérieux par la communauté
internationale et ça sera et vous l'avez
dit à juste titre est l'un des thèmes de
ce sommet européen tout à l'heure
comment est bien libérer ces silos qui
sont menacés d'être atteint d'un
pourrissement tout simplement des
céréales du blé comment les libérer
aussi pour accueillir les nouvelles
productions les nouvelles récoltes qui
vont venir puisqu'on sera bientôt à
l'époque des récoltes en ukraine et
faire en sorte celles que la la la la la
crise de s'accentue pas notamment dans
les pays les plus pauvres on parle
notamment de l'afrique du nord de
l'afrique subsaharienne c'est un vrai
problème et ce n'est pas un hasard
d'ailleurs si le président de l'union
africaine macky sall se joindre à tout à
l'heure au sommet de l'union européenne
que vous avez évoquées pour évoquer
justement cette question des céréales
istres en visioconférence grâce et de
deux rendez-vous deux temps forts qu'on
va vous faire vivre en direct notamment
la conférence de presse de la chef de la
diplomatie française à kiev 1 vous
pouvez vie le moment avec nous à nos
côtés en direct le communiqué du quai
d'orsay
indique que ce voyage et vise à
témoigner de la solidarité de la france
à l'égard du peuple ukrainien face à
l'agression russe la chef de la
diplomatie française qui se rend à kiev
toujours pas des manuels macron à
l'horizon non c'est plutôt le service
minimum pour l'instant du côté français
puisque si l'on prend les chefs d'état
ou de gouvernement vous avez quand même
boris johnson pedro sanchez côtes
espagnoles justin trudeau côté canadien
qui sont déjà venus à kiev depuis
longtemps côté européen vous avez
charles michel bien sûr et ursula ursula
von der leyen ça s'inscrit dans un
contexte assez assez compliquée entre
l'ukraine et la france avec une volonté
d' emmanuel macron certes de soutenir
l'ukraine mais de ne pas froisser un peu
plus l'admirent poutine de ne pas le
braquer il veut il a toujours dit garder
un dialogue avec le président russe avec
lequel d'ailleurs il continue de
s'entretenir par téléphone et puis lors
de son discours du 9 mai c'était à
strasbourg il a justement appelé à ne
pas humilier l'une ou l'autre des
parties parler bien sûr de l'ukraine
mais également de la russie ça s'éteint
c'est un discours qui a été assez mal
pris part volodymyr zelensky qui a vu en
emmanuel macron quelqu'un qui voulait
faire des concessions à la russie et
puis il ya aussi la question de
l'adhésion à l'union européenne on sait
que l'ukraine tape tous les jours à la
porte de l'union européenne à accélérer
le processus d'adhésion mme emmanuel
macron lui ne veut pas d'une adhésion en
tout cas à court ou à moyen terme il l'a
dit ça prendra des années pour que
l'ukraine éventuellement un jour puisse
entrer dans l'union européenne il
préfère un arrimage un arrimage
sécuritaire un arrêt match économique de
l'ukraine a lieu et ça c'est aussi une
source de tension supplémentaire entre
les deux chefs d'état merci beaucoup
bâtisse pour le décrypter